j'ai un syndrome
d'Asperger c'est une forme d'autisme
ouis qu'est-ce qu'on vous reconnaît
comme comme qualité l'intelligence dans
le sens latin c'està-dire la
compréhension pour comprendre c'est ça
le sens premier du terme et les gens
tendent à l'oublier un peu en fait pour
rien au monde il est souhaitable d'avoir
mon cerveau qu'est-ce qu'il a votre
cerveau il fonctionne trop il marche
tout le temps à à des vitesse
vertigineuse que le commun des mortels
ne peux pas comprendre c'est très dur
mais c'est dur pour moi parce que je
suis tout le temps fatigué en fait quand
je suis face à des gens qui font preuve
d'un calme olympien quand je suis face à
des gens qui reflètent une certaine
forme
de bah de bonté d'âme d'amour de partage
en l'occurrence une communauté
monastique comme celle-ci ça peut être
celle-ci ou une autre ça peut être
n'importe quel ordre religieux
j'aimerais trouver cette paix intérieure
et ce calme que je ne possède absolument
pas